[Music]  one thing I love about orange is the new  black is the shows very powerful opening  credits they're so powerful and so  iconic already yeah we sort of did our  version we did our version but man from  the first episode those opening credits  really grabbed me and they're powerful  and they say so much about the show and  how innovative it is and it sets the  mood right away frankly and I have to  say this it's a much better opening  sequence than the one they almost went  with but ditched at the last second take  a look  [Music]  the friends will stand beside you as  long as you're come  cracking lies with crazy eyes and don't  forget  [Music]  people seem to like that line anything  it's so uplifting  [Music]  you